i think first and foremost we should
keep in mind what james madison said we
know what he talked about the dangers of
factionalism
but at the end of his writings he said
the circulation of confidence of trust
is more important than the circulation
of money
and his explanation was if we ever lose
trust in public institutions or with
each other
then
we're lost
[Music]
it is my privilege and honor to welcome
to ford former navy admiral and two-term
member of congress from the great state
of pennsylvania and also my fellow
presidential candidate in the 2020 cycle
joe sestak welcome joe well andrew
it's very fun to be back with you indeed
my friend
uh we have some stories to tell from the
trail for sure but your story is epic
and fascinating uh i first
heard of you
when you were in the throes of various
congressional and senate races i didn't
know the full backstory which we'll get
into but you spent 31 years
in the u.s navy including as a
three-star admiral so my first question
is the question that everyone has has
for you i'm sure
what did you think of top gun
one and two
well a lesson to take away from this one
andrew is tom cruise flew an f-14 in the
first one and the second one is aboard a
joint strike fighter
but you know unlike what we do in
america when we close down a coal mine
and we go to uh
producing solar power panels
the middle class the enlisted
of that aircraft care we didn't throw
them out
and say you don't know how to work on
this we trained them for the next step
and so when i watched it what was really
missing in that movie and all i could
think about was the 5 000 sailors on an
aircraft carrier their average age
andrew
19 and a half oh my gosh and so that's
what i think about i know tom cruise
gets all the glory and well he should
but as general ackermayov when he came
on over here he was chief of the soviet
union general staff
and admiral crowell took him everywhere
admiral crowle took him into barbecue in
arkansas he took him to military bases
his last stop was aboard an aircraft
carrier
and when they had left it and come back
he said
admiral crowl asked general alchemy what
do you most get out of your entire time
in america
what did you most appreciate
and he said your enlisted men now it's
men and women today i know that
but that's what he said and so to me
that's what built america great and
that's what made tom cruise is so
meaningful to me crew two pictures so
meaningful to me i took a different take
on it but that's all i could think about
is those men and women making sure that
plane goes off and takes off in the
catapult and all the captain does is
give him a salute
knowing that that youth of america you
could trust
that he did his job right that that
plane would work
well you were in charge of how many uh
thousands of sailors well there's about
uh i think i had approximately 15 000
sailors seals and marines
and uh you know in the evening
i'd always either go down on the mess
decks to eat with them or i'd have six
or seven of them like boast mates up to
eat with me because that nice little
seed capping and so
that's the great thing about the
military they come from every state
heavily
we don't get as many from up in the
northeastern part or the you know along
the northern part now if you look at a
demographic map of who comes in it's
more of a swath from pennsylvania around
but you get them all all races
everything and you know even before
don't ask don't tell was out there we
all knew who was gay and all i can
remember with don't ask don't tell came
up
somebody would come up and says i gotta
tell you captain um and all i could
think about is please don't tell me
but i don't want to lose you but that's
what you learn in this great global
canvas
of american service i wore the cloth of
our country for 31 years
and what i learned from there that we do
have more in common than indifference is
is what i really still believe today
well your dad served in the navy you
followed in his footsteps you finished
second year class at the u.s naval
academy and so it begged the question to
me who the heck fitted first like what
happened to that guy
i gotta i gotta i mentioned one other
person though my mom you know together
as they said they raised eight kids but
she also served our country
she served almost three decades as a
high school math teacher because i
honestly believe education is our
homeland defense our real homeland
defense
yeah your mom being a math teacher is is
incredible and you ended up
founding a non-profit for stem education
uh much later in your career you're also
a phd yourself how the heck does someone
get a phd from harvard while
being a navy officer because i saw that
and said like if anyone could do that
it's joe but um you know it doesn't seem
easy
well you know we
pre we
value education so much in our service
when i was departing you could not
become a senior chief petty officer
until unless you had earned at least an
associate's degree
in college
you could not you could not even as i
was entering become a
officer of a mid-grade lieutenant
commander commander unless you had a
master's degree
so
when i graduated native academy they let
a few of us go off to civilian
institutions because it's good for us
not just to have our own self-centered
education system as we do out in
monterey naval post graduate school
but i wanted to go to sea first and i
want to be in engineering down there
with the boilermakers and so i came back
applied to go to harvard
and got there
and i studied political economy and
government and that
the navy purposely sends a number of us
around to various civilian schools for
that so that then later on
when you're sure i mean warfighting was
my specialty skill my sub specialty was
strategy and policy and political
analysis so i got to went to work for
general colin powell that's why i went
to the now security council the white
house to work for president clinton so
that you're able to balance where does
the military fit in in this broad
spectrum of u.s interest but above all
what it helps you do
is understand militaries
can stop a problem andrew
they cannot fix a problem so before you
decide
that you are going to use our military
make sure you know how it's going to end
before you think it's wise to begin and
i think looking in recent history you
will see that error was made we didn't
think that through
well you commanded thousands of sailors
during uh the gulf war uh and then
served
uh as a national security council member
uh under the clinton administration you
were you were elevated to three-star
admiral and then you were given a task
around hey how do we ready the navy for
conflicts of the future
and here's where it seems like some some
politics started entering the the
picture where you stood up and were like
hey you know one of the big threats is
going to be cyber security so we should
really be investing resources in that
which by the way sounds eminently
sensible and you were ahead of your time
because you were saying this in in what
year
this was 2005. yeah so in 2005
our friend joe sestak the admiral is
like hey guys we should probably be
investing in cyber security um which
ended up being unpopular as an opinion
then um because there were a lot of
people that wanted more
uh traditional
equipment and collateral on the rest of
it uh and so
your incredibly distinguished career you
have 10 medals that i saw
uh you're a three-star admiral you're
making a case for the future that i
think now everyone sees it as completely
accurate and prescient uh but then what
what happened next yes i came back from
the war first off uh i had gone on the
ground initially because after i'd been
in the pentagon walked out of it the
plane came in just after i walked out
and i went walked back to see the
destruction
about two days later the chief naval
operation said you're going to head up
and set up a strategic and operational
to some degree anti-terrorism took me
under the ground in afghanistan for a
short mission beginning of the war came
out commanded that aircraft carry a
battle group as we struck
i came back and the chief of naval
operations said joe you're going to be
my black hat analyst
i'm going to give you 10 million dollars
which is decimal dust in the military as
you know andrew
and 100 people and anything that comes
to me he said as a three or four star
from a three or four star admiral euro
as a two star at the time was going to
analyze it and i did he said i want your
opinion i want your opinion based upon
the facts coming out of your analysis
so out of that i propose that the navy
having war gained it because i had this
wonderful young man who could see the
future and i love youth because they're
not burdened with experience that i
could stand there listen to him and then
we war gained it went to nsa other
places that were just beginning to get
in cyberspace warfare
and our argument was
that the future domain of warfare is
cyberspace we should not and i and have
375 ships about 240 250 is what we need
because you need to carry some munitions
to the fight
but
if you are blind deaf then you are dumb
and so 17 out of 18 recent war games by
rand have shown that the united states
gets it and the words used by its
analyst were
ass handed to it because they break our
networks that connects our brain to our
nervous systems but when we propose that
it was not good i'd become a three-star
i was told to go breathe the hill we
submitted to the hill we're going to cut
down on these ships and we want to put
the money into the domain of cyber
warfare it's actually probably going to
be less expensive and stationed aircraft
carrying guam because for example if
china were to as you saw some recent
indications of how unhappy they were
with speaker pelosi's visits
they will do this unlike having watched
how long putin took to build up how long
we took to build up in iraq that we're
going to come from san diego at about 35
30 knots maybe 35 knots
they are going to go at the speed of
nanoseconds because they will make
everybody blind and deaf and immediately
try to occupy that so that is when i uh
chief naval operations left
the new chief of naval operations as is
his right
decided that nope we needed 375 ships
and yet today the defense science board
came out two years ago and said not one
major weapon system
in the u.s military do we have
confidence hasn't already been
compromised because as you know
bloomberg did a report a few years ago
saying that even in the servers that
apple
amazon cia drones they mentioned as well
as aegis ships
had chips put in them that could awaken
like a soviet old soviet sleeper agent
and do damage or they weren't secure of
of
of
being able to go in and damage the
software and now two years ago the
secretary of the navy has said had a
report done that said
the navy is focused on 375-ship mindset
it doesn't understand the domain of
warfare they have to protect against the
cyber
i still believe that's a challenge today
i've written an article a year ago about
this and i just hope things change
because at the end of the day
it is about the lives of our sailors and
that iron triangle congress
you know president eisenhower talks
about the military-industrial complex
the rumor word is that he crossed out
the word congress in the last draft it
was a congressional military industrial
complex that holds on to things much
like the battleship and the carrier era
warfare just before the real war began
and luckily the carrier one all went
over
and now a word from our sponsor
better help we all have good days and
bad days days when we're set to be able
to solve the problems in front of us and
then days when the problems seem really
big and daunting the question is how do
we stay in a positive problem-solving
mode more frequently when it feels like
the deck can be stacked against us i
first saw a therapist when i was a
teenager and have been a huge believer
ever since my brother's a clinical
psychologist the fact is therapy is one
of the best ways you can actually figure
out how to solve the problems in your
head and if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option it's convenient accessible
affordable entirely online you can get
matched with a therapist after filling
out a brief survey and switch at any
time when you want to be a better
problem solver therapy can help get you
there visit betterhelp.com yang today to
get 10 percent off your first month
that's betterhelp.com
[Music]
well you were referred to at the time by
uh the chief of naval operations as a
patriots patriot a man of courage uh you
ended up leaving
service which i'm sure at that point uh
comprised the totality of your adult
life and identity move home to
pennsylvania
and then decide to run for congress in a
district that is written off as
completely uncompetitive uh i i think
you were down by 30 points to start and
no one thought it was a good idea you
reached out to the democrats uh the dccc
they thought it was a terrible idea um
and then you decided to to get in any
way and somehow won that race first of
all i asked a classmate of mine went to
rival high schools off the naval academy
off to war the same battle group
together to run my to run with my
brother my staff
and yeah it was a hard slog you know it
wasn't just seeing a light at the end of
the tunnel we had to build the tunnel
and so
what we did is worked hard i mean
i was out there at every train station
and i'll never forget handed a brochure
to everybody and you know as they're
there at the train station every morning
and because you can't fundraise between
six and eight as you know andrew so and
i remember this young woman saying to me
when she looked at it
i said i'm a retired navy admiral
and i'm running national security that
begins at home in health security
because i want everyone to have what
saved my daughter's life and she looked
at me and said admiral you got to be
kidding me democrat
and so
i got a lot of support from republicans
though that's how you swung a district
that no one thought was competitive
that's right and the morning after the
election andrew
i called up
uh charlie who was the head of
republican party
it was an
uh very uh hard marine
and said charlie
first call i made the next day can i
come over for a cup of coffee
i did i knocked on the door we went in
and we still
talked to one another we talked every
two three days the point is i learned in
the navy that the captain doesn't get
off the bridge wing and go down to the
boiler room and talk with them not just
with those that are right next helping
them navigate the ship you know those
top side but also those down there you
know sweating away and working
you're not going to make it so we
worked hard and when you came into our
office
you weren't allowed to say the word
republican or democrat and we worked and
went anywhere any place anything the
result was as you probably know andrew
i got reelected by 20 points and didn't
spend a penny of the three and a half
million that i had raised on an ad
and i think it goes back to what i
learned in the navy
people do want to trust
and if they trust they're willing to
listen and talk
and it doesn't mean they vote for you
but the anger the misunderstanding isn't
there 10 health healthcare town halls i
loved it because that's why i got into
my country back for saving my daughter
we took what soon became known as
romneycare and had not passed yet
and that's what i ran on
and as i explained obamacare the tea
party patriots were there at everyone
i'd get there an hour before shake all
their hands stay three and a half hours
until they were
walked out and the last one and i still
tell you it's my one of my favorite
photos is they asked the delaware county
tea party pages to ask for a photo with
me i mean i really do believe we if that
we can regain that trust
in the democratic system in someone who
can help us understand like abe lincoln
did
a house will fall if it's you know the
divided will fall i think that is what
is most important i think you said what
i said in the presidential campaign i
was told
mr trump president trump
is not the problem he was the symptom of
a problem where people felt this cis
process was not accountable or fair to
them
and if you don't look at it through
their eyes walking in their shoes then
you can't just keep lobbing back and
forth artillery shells of single-minded
cultural issues and expect to bring this
nation together again
yeah yeah
and speaking of walking
uh
in someone else's shoes you walked
across the state of pennsylvania i think
in the next big campaign which was a
statewide us senate race and here's
where it gets weird where you won your
congressional election by 20 points it's
very clear to anyone saying that you
have
amazing bipartisan appeal because if a
republican here is retired navy admiral
31 years of service 10 medals are like
okay i get it
this guy's as patriotic
as the day is long
but the democrats for whatever reason
really don't want you to run and this is
one thing i i actually noticed this even
as a civilian contemporaneously at the
time i was like why the heck are
democrats not piling in behind joe
sestak and instead they were behind
another guy that you beat in the primary
i uh you're talking that second senate
race right now i believe correct the
first race i beat senator spector who
had changed from being
uh republican to being a democrat
now that alone isn't what bothered me it
bothered me that our leadership could
embrace someone
who had actually tried to humiliate
anita hill
as the democratic fellow senators stood
in the testimony she gave about sexual
harassment by now supreme court clarence
thomas
and i didn't agree with that
and so
i
ran against him against the party's
desires
beat him
then they hear the tea party closely not
but that next race
i could tell from that year of the tea
party that politics had changed
people no longer wanted to know who i
was
navy admiral
democrat
are you kidding
they want what do you stand for
what issues do you think about this
what do you bring from knowing about the
world having visited 80 countries in
your career
now they wanted to know if i knew what
they had gone through in that great
recession
to where
democrats and republicans in the one
place you should have a wall
they tore it down because a wall needs
to be on wall street to keep
out an accountability in and because
they tore it down
it just collapsed our economy and who
got hurt
the carnage of millions of jobs and
livelihoods and they wanted to know
you know as much as other things
who's accountable for this who can i
trust that would ever say i was
accountable not just for the my
intentions but for the deed so i decided
to walk across the great state of
pennsylvania
and halfway and it was great
you know i had two phone calls on the
way across uh two special ones
one was from a republican actually
wasn't a phone call he walked outside
his car dealership and yelled out
because i had my flight jacket on
admiral
i'm a republican but i love what you're
doing every day was a town hall talking
to the media anybody could come not just
bust in from democrats the second call
was from this democratic leadership that
controlled the money and said stop
walking no
yes
that's crazy
and just fundraise
so pennsylvania is a very long state uh
lengthwise like how many miles is that
and how the heck long would it take to
walk across it yes it took i i wish i i
wish i remember the facts but they were
it was
i started in philadelphia right on the
river and uh came all the way across i
think
it was 28 days i think it was about
right yeah i thought i thought i would
thought 20 miles a day and i stopped
everywhere i got to tell you i
i love it and again my daughter
uh had given me a sign in my first race
that i carried with me joe sestak is
walking in your shoes
and uh and i meant it and even on the
presidential race i had that little sign
up on my website and i think that's what
we have to do you have to see it from
the other guy's perspective doesn't mean
you have to agree
but it doesn't mean you just have to
antagonize by just lobbing things
without at least listening it's not some
problems with a disgruntled family but
still it's a family if you're listening
well i i felt like both of your senate
races were such missed opportunities
where the the first time i want to say
it seems like the democrats
piled in behind arlen specter and
everyone called you saying hey get out
of arlen's way there apparently they
offered you a job so you'd get out of
arlen's way and you were like no no i'm
going to do this then you beat arlen
specter in the primary and you know at
that point too i thought okay like
everyone should freaking pile in behind
joe because clearly he is a better uh
he's a better candidate like uh more
connected to folks and you lose very
narrowly to pat toomey um and this is
2010 i believe
and then you come back again after
losing narrowly and it's like the
democrats didn't learn their lesson and
they backed someone else against you
again i think is it
is this all correct yeah there was
whatever reason you would think you know
people think the military it's yes or no
sir oh it's anything but
you lose that trust of your sailors i
mean
things cannot work as well as you might
like them to
and so i think there was found the same
thing in the democratic senate
leadership
uh you know i was asked to come down and
meet with them they told me who i would
hire who i would fire
literally
and they were nice about it but says
here's what we want to do
hire this washington firm i didn't want
a washington firm
[Laughter]
anything
you know and then finally it was that
final phone call as the senator said on
it about the fundraising said fine
this is a very interesting conversation
and hung up
i really felt
that the dynamics of politics had
changed
it wasn't any longer just about blasting
money out there and you know
if you remember trump didn't put a lot
of money into that race of his compared
to others in the beginning
people
found a false prophet in my opinion
but
they just wanted to know and the media i
was getting was fantastic and it wasn't
the end-all and be-all and sure it could
have said yes and returned but i really
felt
strongly
that if you just rent your soul for a
while
for a principal for a while that when
you get down there
they will think they own it and i when i
did a walk i said i'm an independent who
happens to be a democrat because i was
an independent in the navy i got out to
run on as a democrat because they had
the very best approach to health care as
i told everybody in the military
everybody has health care men and women
get the same exact pay you get a pension
when you're done and as i told you in
the tom cruise question you gave me you
get training for a lifetime so then you
have another career prepared for out
there and then i'd pause and i'd say
everybody in the military is a democrat
they just don't realize it wow
independent because i took
away from the navy accountability and
andrew if i could just tell you one
story please
on that aircraft carrier that you asked
about at the very beginning with tom
cruise
is he sitting in that plane waiting to
take off
every so often the plane's cap is the
captain of the plane you know the pilot
is told shut down the plane
something's wrong on the indicators or
else we need a different plane over
afghanistan not an f-14 an ea-6b
but that captain has turned on his
engines with his brakes on
and then they strapped into a catapult
that when he releases the brake and they
push the button it slingshots you into
the air but now you're sitting there
rocking back and forth like that and
that in that thing and you're rocking
i mean you take off walt disney has no
better ride than that
and then they tell you to shut it down
and that pilot
is doesn't want to shut his or her
brakes down uh engines off until they
know they've been unhooked from that
catapult
because if they you shut your engine
down somebody by mistake pushes the
button off you go for your last wild
ride yeah
so a young youth
probably average age as i said 19 half
comes under that plane and unhooks it
from the catapult where the pilot can't
see under the belly of the plane walks
in front of the plane gives a very
simple signal like this andrew
and then that youth of america could be
from california could be from utah
doesn't move
until the pilot has shut down their
plane
open up the cockpit and gotten safely on
deck
and that youth has said everything
that this nation yearns for
what it most wants
he said or she said that youth go ahead
you can trust me
because i'm willing to be accountable
not for my intentions
but for the deed and if i made a mistake
and you start heading over to that your
death i'm going right there
with you to mine
i can't find a lot of americans
who feel that any very many people in
washington dc would ever stand in front
of that plane for them
that accountability is the second thing
i took away from service
above party
above
everything but nation
and i really believe that's what this
nation really wants and why frankly
i joined the ford party
well thank you so much joe we do have to
rekindle that sense of trust uh and
belonging in community and millions of
americans and certainly having a 20 year
old stand in front of the plane saying
look i've unhooked this and if i haven't
then we're both going to die i mean
there's nothing
more more
uh inspiring than that because
you know you've placed your life in the
hands of someone
and people in service have had to do
that over and over again you know for
for years
uh it is that kind of spirit that the
country needs and i'm so grateful to you
for
believing in forward as a way to
hopefully accomplish that do you think
that
and this is something that i've actually
gone um
somewhat deep on do you think that some
kind of mandatory national service might
help instill
a sense of community uh or belonging or
trust
uh because you've probably seen some of
the proposals in that direction
yes i do
in the book i published called walking
in your shoes is a chapter on national
service
whenever military men and women come
together they always ask where did you
serve
or if you see somebody's ribbons you can
often tell where they serve but if
you're a vet you always say first
question and i was at a vfw the other
day do an event for a young man who was
running and
where did you serve
imagine if someone said that all
americans come together said would you
do your national service not just the
military wow because people it takes
about often a year of training before
they send you out to that nuclear
reactor remember 19 and a half years old
average age they run a nuclear reactor
you want to make things sailor proof by
being well trained
and so
maybe it's a year peace corps maybe it's
a year
teaching in america maybe it's a year
whatever yes do i think that could help
instill once again the community bonding
that has somewhat disappeared and then i
also believe this though that i also
took away if you happen to do something
overseas
you mentioned
that i established a
non-profit first global
it brought together
uh within nine months at constitution
hall across from the white house
158 nations as you well know high school
teams
sixty percent of whom had never had a
stem core course had never touched a
robot but it was the first high school
or robotic olympics and we put together
800 americans in an internet in an
internet peace corps
and they would go over to the congo
where you read they're having challenge
today or miley where i still stay stay
in touch with and they would train them
of how after we shipped them the robot
to put it together to compete the best
way it might then when they came here to
america there was three teams on each
side
and and the thing was i did is i it
wasn't just for the vacation and try to
show the leaders this got to get
everywhere stem
but i learned in the military when i
arrived off afghanistan with a battle
group with my 12
ships including the carrier there was 22
other ships waiting their force another
armada japan that had not been outside
the sea of japan
since my father fought them in world war
ii germany was there
and
the italians they were coming a little
late but they sent a message that said
we will be there
because america has been attacked
and we will be there for them
i learned that america's greatest power
and i think this could come from your
question of having a national service
corps is you also learn that our
greatest power is the power to convene
to bring others together for a common
cause that serves us all i don't care if
it's uh climate change
i don't care if it's the ukraine
situation today
learning that in a community of those
who are doing national service
particularly overseas like peace
cornwall bodes a long way but right here
in america doing it with americans
together from california to arkansas
would also bring that same sense
together we have more in common than in
differences you know i'm sure people
listening to you right now are thinking
to themselves holy cow like this guy
would make a great president which by
the way i do think you'd make a a great
president um you and i spent some spend
some time together on the trail in 2020
and i was blown away
by how
you didn't seem to get a fair shake uh
and and there's been something of a
pattern honestly where i i feel like for
whatever reason the democrats don't seem
to know what they have
in you or had in you
um in terms of the u.s senate race in
pennsylvania i think you should have
been a u.s senator and then i think you
should have been the president honestly
like that's the way i
see it
uh
and when you and i were on the trail
together
um you walked across the state of new
hampshire kind of uh again reflecting
um a bit of a pattern for for you which
is just trying to meet people and put
yourself in their shoes and come across
as a human being which is kind of the
opposite of the
um the
approach to politics that most people
have it's just you working hard
um to meet people where they are
and i thought that
i mean i was you know in new hampshire
not the same way you were when you
walked across the state um how long did
that take by the way
that was a lot shorter
[Laughter]
seven about i think it was 11 days but i
have a norister that came across one
time and uh you know and i passed this
street called hell street in the middle
of it and i i as i remember i put it up
there says i think this nor'easter must
be one from hell
if i could enter that walk
was
meaningful
i uh because i would stop at a place
every
day to make a point
so one of the places i went to was
where they were learning um how to work
with you know artisans that were
actually there
that had we're working in plumbing and
how to learn about the new plumbing
tools and alliances getting re-educated
you know i'm a strong believer that's in
my book that said we need training for a
lifetime because we put less into
training and retraining
our blue
collar workers our enlisted men and
women that general may have said they're
your greatest strength and they are
still our greatest strength today
in the civilian world than any other
oecd developed nation
so i can understand why they sometimes
seem to sit there
and and think of a song by pink called
what about us
when they see all of a sudden college
scholarships but they want to know about
us why isn't this a win-win where
those tractors you saw out there in iowa
as i talked to one person running back
and forth in a parade said
hey can you tell me um
what do you do and she said i'm a video
a digital agronomist
and i am going to uh make sure we don't
need
drivers of those tractors
well where's the program that really
does say what about us and that's what i
mean by walking other shoes
one other example if you don't mind
please
each veterans day even after i left
congress into the epidemic because i
didn't want them to think i'd forgotten
them to a penitentiary
uh grateful penitentiary was one off i
often went for and i did the same in new
hampshire up there
when i went to the one in new hampshire
i learned
uh that this was one where they walk you
in as a prisoner
and just like you're walking into a
dental office
they got 2k two uh
uh bar
rooms here with bars and then you could
sit down there in a chair
and if you behave they're going to treat
you
as a respectful human being
and that's how the whole place was run i
just walked all through that maximum
security prison
i also did this and learned a lot about
de-escalation which as you well know is
watching many videos recently we have to
understand as tough as it is
that is the right approach and when you
have something beginning
untoward in violence perhaps rather than
thinking you must take care of it in a
very aggressive way and i learned that
lesson there in that prison
but i also learned that these when i
went to the vets there in gradeford i
was out there in with you and i got a
call if you don't mind
and uh it was great for prison on the
line an inmate uh got on the line
and said because i used to go there each
year and said and he goes hey
joe
the guys have heard
that you're running for president
they want you to know
they're going to organize philadelphia
for you
wow what presidential candidate has that
cocktail story huh but then my point was
again service
veterans never forget it
back to your original point about
bringing people together for national
service yeah yeah maybe i'm reaching a
little bit here
but when you look at the recidivism
programs a lack thereof
and we have to keep in mind it was
president bush who was the only
president in america who ever mentioned
recidivism in a state of the union
message and then put three and a half
million uh 350 million dollars into that
program
and yet we still have about an 85
percent or so we sit at this rate in
many of our programs i bring all this up
is you need to put yourself in other
people's shoes to and go there to really
understand why they view things the way
they do and try to correct the view if
it's wrong but if not see if you can
work together you mentioned your
daughter uh earlier she unfortunately
had
major health problems when she was young
that she recovered from
but then they recurred
around the same time that you were
looking at running for president and i'm
sure that must have been uh
extraordinarily painful and difficult
yes um
she's a warrior
um
i've
um
there's there's no one like her ever met
and it did come back
and so
everything's off the table
and we just worked it through
and the doctor said after
six eight months whatever i i think
we've got it back in remission again
i got in that first race in congress as
i told you as a payback tour to my
country
because we were in a hospital room
after they first said they couldn't get
it at a military hospital and she had
four to maybe six so months
but they couldn't get it out the rest
section and it was glioblastoma we went
to children's hospital because my health
care plan permitted me in the military
to do that
and they saved their life
for for quite a period of time until it
came back the second time
and i had to pay back my country that's
why i ran in healthcare this time
i thought we were okay
and again then i got into the
presidential race
uh
but as you probably know you do know is
uh
simultaneously it was time to say uh
it's unfair to ask people
continue to support me it was also uh
it just then when uh the cancer had uh
reoccurred a third time
so and all but it's uh
the greatest thing in life was to have
her
uh you know i'm so
sorry joe
i mean as as a parent myself man i can
only imagine what what that must have
been but as you said i mean uh i'm sure
uh
she was the greatest gift uh
for both you and your your wife uh while
she was with us she was wise um
i remember once she was about eight
years old and
um
i said to her hey han how how am i doing
raising you she leaned over and
touched my shoulder with her small hand
and said oh
daddy daddy daddy
i'm raising you
[Laughter]
every day i changed because of her and
grew up
[Music]
and i i didn't realize that the extent
of what your family was
dealing with when we were on the trail
i do think that you didn't get a fair
shake or a real look while we were
running and one of the stories that
i ran across was that major news
networks wouldn't have you on
even to talk about foreign policy which
by the way you're about a million times
more qualified than
just about
anyone anyone else
given um your vast global
um
military leadership uh and travel and
experience so my fans sometimes got
agitated where they're like hey yang's
not getting a fair look um which i
appreciate it thank you yan gang but it
was but like i felt like there were
other candidates who were in the same
boat and i'd say that you were very much
at the top of that list
um was there ever a point when you were
like hey guys
three star admiral 10 medals
two-term member of congress from a swing
state
like you know you might wanna
give me a microphone or put a point of
camera this way
did you ever have that feeling
of course uh we even had a memo from one
of the uh
lead uh
you know the cnn msnbc in fox and from
one of them we had a
friend on the station sent me a copy of
the memo saying not to have joe sestak
on
and the other one had a good friend but
he just said ain't going to happen
but you know
i think i kind of learned that
complaining about the media for
politician is like a sea captain
complaining about the sea
and you just gotta accept it i do think
that
it's a challenge at times
yes for me
but it also has i think at times
you know hurt the nation a little bit
in other circumstances as the head
former head i think it was a cbs said
you know um
mr
trump is great for our ratings you know
and
how could they miss
who and what he was going to bring or
even the win the first time
but if you were out there on the deck
plates not just
in a studio
i can remember after
they put over about just about 10
million dollars the democratic party did
via unions even though my union voting
record was like 100 percent and uh and
also direct from the ds uh democratic
central campaign committee into for my
opponent because we were like 24 points
up with three four weeks to go and then
all the money came in on an ad that the
washington post gave four pinocchios to
as being false and called a sleazy way
to win
i couldn't complain it was over and okay
but
i uh
i can
it's like they didn't i was out there
after that was over and went back as i
did the first time to every one of the
67 counties to say thank you
i also because a philadelphia
congressional boss in pittsburgh
question box wouldn't let me go to any
other democratic events
so i went to like 200 half american
churches i went back to thank them
individually too
but the first county i went back to
scranton county
uh
oh they came together
you know and i thanked them for their
support and i remember this one woman
stood up to his vice chair i something
at the time said i just want you to know
that i have relatives of mine who have
voted democrat this entire
life period of theirs
but they're going to go for trump
and i knew she was talking about her
and right then i said no if i'm getting
this down on the death plates it means
somebody better be alert aware that this
is not you know just a joke happening of
you know but again i step back to what
you also said he was a symptom of a
problem
and i do believe that problem was why
couldn't we earn their trust
and when you're doing things from
washington dc even the media
and constantly lobbying artillery shells
of as i said of these culture issues
back and forth and never listening
very rarely saying there's a dialogue
because you think you'll get primaried
out you're not willing to you're willing
for the expedient to lose your principle
i think
that that is what has been most damaging
and caused it
oh you're such a generous spirit about
it joe because uh what you just referred
to i believe was they piled a bunch of
money into your primary opponent uh
katie mcginty
uh during the your intended rematch um
in 2016 against pat toomey and then
mcginty would go on to lose pretty
handily i i i think
um and i think you would have won that
race the whole thing just struck me as
so bizarre
where
you were clearly
the
uh the candidate with the broadest
crossover appeal you'd won your district
which was like
like either a swing or a slightly
republican district by 20 points uh you
know you'd lost narrowly against the the
incumbent senator despite not having
democratic support and then instead of
learning their lesson being like okay
this time we just back joe sestak and
you know win this thing they decide to
for whatever reason like pile money
behind your your primary opponent who
then goes on to lose so that like the
the whole thing like if i'm you i mean
heck i'm angry on your behalf and i'm
not even you
um but uh you know like the
and the fact that you kind of saw some
of the
loss of trust manifesting in people
moving to trump before anyone else may
not make sense to me because you're
actually close to the ground talking to
people
perhaps you could say a silver lining
around it was i think
the dscc perhaps
learned by burning its hand
that
trying to be an authoritarian
circle down there
and think you know what's best for each
state because pennsylvania is different
than new york
uh a lot of commonality of values but
the culture is you know it's a little
different than down in manhattan
wonderfully different you know
and and i think that when you look i
think it's one out of every four i could
has some
pennsylvania has some family member who
has served
wow
no wonder they love you there joe i mean
look that nowhere up but it's a lot you
know it's interesting when we were out
there in iowa together because i got out
there late because i i wasn't gonna end
unless my daughter was on the road to
that recovery and and and made sure that
we had three
months of mris that said not there
and
i got in and when i arrived everybody
had their volunteers because i was like
the last aboard the caboose
so i went to a homeless shelter for vets
and said hey can i give you guys a
dollar above minimum wage and you'll
pass out brochures because i love to do
you know
love to run in parades and as you
remember out there parades i mean if a
farmer has a grows more strawberries
than last year they throw a parade and i
remember i called one woman off and said
how many people you think is going to be
there so we already brochures god says
well
probably more than normal we haven't had
a parade in about four weeks
so i always got everywhere and ran these
parades and i had these wonderful
veterans from the homeless shelter
passing my brochure out the very first
parade
and i would run back and forth and shake
every hair and learn that in my
congressional district i did it all the
time because the you know
87 of all elected officials were
republicans and the county
ones would drive in a car down the
middle of it and i'm running back and
forth shaking everybody's hand but i had
a picture of me
shaking president clinton's hand the old
officers was in uniform or briefing him
on something
and i would say every tenth person there
and this i can remember that first ray
was in a it wasn't in a des moines it
was out there in the royals
and uh
every tenth person would stand up
as i approached them said i want to
thank you for your service as he hands
it and everyone i went down the path and
shook almost invariably one out of three
of those with thanks for your service
and
yeah i think it is and here's why i
think
that people in the rural areas and so
many of them come came into our military
but that was it they feel they've served
our nation by giving them energy
over the decades they feel they've
served our nation by giving them
agriculture over the decades and that
they served our nation in every war
even heavily in war
and now all of a sudden their
livelihoods are at risk
whether it's actors or coal mines or
whatever and
all of a sudden they're saying wait a
minute
what's happening and who's out here
trying to help me when i got out there i
heard there was a
former
vice superintendent or something from
newark out there in
in iowa so i gave him a call and he was
republican somebody had told me and i
said what's it like out here and he'd
gone out there for his final tour as a
and had his police chief of kind of a
rural
semi-urban area but lots of royal
how's the crime rate out here because
this iowa niceness is pretty awesome
you saw it andrew yeah yeah i enjoyed it
too it's real and uh he said
it's not the robberies not the murderers
what it is is
people who've lost their jobs they're on
opioids now all of a sudden there's
domestic abuse all of a sudden there's
petty theft and there's no way you know
the i am their service uh networks uh
service network social network he says
that's what it is and you found you know
i looked into it and uh all but four of
those counties two were stable in
population two were growing
and the rest were decreasing yeah all
private hospitals had closed before the
three or four years got there so it's
tough and we've got to look at it from
their angle
yeah i i was in rural communities in
iowa where schools were closing or
consolidating they were combining
two schools into one or uh in like
closing schools i mean if you're in that
kind of environment and then all of a
sudden your kid has to you know go to
the next town over because you're a
local school closed i mean you know that
like you're you're going to be
uh receptive to you know like a a
different message and you're going to
feel like hey like who the heck is
looking out for us because
um you know things are are trending
negatively um for the people in their
lives
uh there were
folks i spoke to too who were you know
like struggling with their family
members are struggling with opiate
addiction
um
uh which isn't something i think people
associate necessarily with
uh places like rural iowa but uh but it
was there
yeah and andrew i mean i know you feel
like because we've talked about it
before
what an experience it was priceless no
matter how it came out to have seen what
we saw and all of america and and one
more thing about those opioids
you know i can remember reading an
article
now as purdue and everybody is being
taken to court about uh all the
illicit use of these opioids that were
being pushed by prescriptions and other
things and people keeping a blind eye to
it in the pharmaceutical industry which
i'm very grateful for they saved our
daughter's life for a couple times
you know she wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for it wouldn't have been here
with us as long as we wanted it wasn't
for them that said
we knew
in another previous to trump that
you know and washington post did a
wonderful expose on it and a book just
came out about two months ago about it
that because of these pill mills
in west virginia for example the rural
areas
something like a million pills being
shipped there either every day or every
month for a town of 2000 yeah and and we
dia won't investigate it but they were
shut down first administratively and
second by a
law passed by congress
in a
polite delicate way so to speak that it
wasn't so obvious
and that to me is this accountability
issue
um and you know we've had over 500 and
i don't you know don't mind it but we've
had too many over 502 decades people
leave public service elected and go off
to become lobbyist and all one of whom
went off to become in the justice
department helped close that down went
to become a lobbyist
for one of the pharmaceuticals i bring
this up because
what i meant i meant that is what about
me when they felt they've already as in
their heritage has given so much to this
nation and yes
we do need to make sure that as we do
change what are true discriminations and
other things that it's a win-win
rather than a win and an apparent
feeling of loss here
yeah i i also
have extraordinarily positive
feelings and memories uh from the time
in iowa and new hampshire
and you get the sense that the people of
this country
are
good
and want a lot of the same things
and they're being failed in my opinion
by a system that's not actually
delivering
what they want um and also is pitting us
against each other as you say like you
know on one side or another just bombing
artillery shells at each other
rather than solving the problems that
people are experiencing in iowa new
hampshire or new york city or california
so
thrilled to be working with yuan forward
and hopefully we can
do something to help provide a positive
uh
alternative to the tit for tat uh
character dramas uh of the day and i
know that you're intent on trying to
rebuild the nation's trust thrilled that
you're going to be joining me and i'm
sure hundreds of other people in houston
on september 24th so that's going to be
incredible
but what are your hopes for ford what
can we do to actually reinvigorate the
sense of community and trust that people
have lost
yes i think first and foremost we should
keep in mind what james madison said we
know what he talked about the dangers of
factionalism
but at the end of his writings he said
the circulation of confidence of trust
is more important than the circulation
of money
and his explanation was if we ever lose
trust in public institutions or with
each other
then
we're lost and i think if we keep that
in mind
that it isn't just about winning
first because how can you then govern
that if we are out there listening and
explaining and i do think that as we go
down this road i was very happy
just like abraham lincoln and others
joined a new party back in the 1850s the
republican party the one third party
that definitely grew up to be
significant
that they did it for one issue at the
time
no extension of slavery into the western
territories and he kept the house from
dividing
with that as our model and the motto and
motto model and the motto of j madison i
think that we can then slowly having
listen
make sure we work on what i call
pragmatic issues that's how the navy
does it we give health care to everybody
not because we're liberal two-thirds of
military members are republicans that's
why i felt at home in my republican
district
you know and and yet it's practical
in the first u.s congress held in new
york
because they mandated all sailors
on our merchant ships how to have health
care
because they didn't want scurvy
to destroy our economy
and they had to pay part of it
they didn't want so as we had to bring
our raw materials to england to be made
into furniture and other items and
brought back and without a healthy fleet
we would
not have a strong economy our
original tea party forefathers
understood that as i told the yes
today's tea party pete back in 2010 when
was happening we need to show
pragmatically why things work not as a
ideology not as the culture but
pragmatically and so why don't we have
training for a lifetime when in the
military what a waste it would be if tom
cruise didn't have the mechanic that was
on the f14 trained to be ready for the
jsf and so i think slowly but surely we
can't if we listen i have hopes that the
ford party then
letting everyone know that they want to
make sure that we really do believe the
biggest issue of trust from americans so
let me add the vote for us or anything
but yeah i got it okay
second laying out those issues that are
pragmatic that america needs otherwise
yeah we've got something done through
the congress recently
but will the next congress rip it out or
what and we can't afford that if i could
though i also believe on foreign policy
we need to understand
that today
we just like that war in afghanistan
where i had 22 ships from other nations
with us
that we are all stronger
with u.s leadership but who can't do it
alone whether it's against
authoritarianism like china
or russia or whether it's against
climate change
and we need to be able to have people
who can help lead this world and explain
to americans why
their own economy their own jobs are
going to be better and protected if we
are working with the proper programs
jointly whether it's africa which will
soon have the largest middle class in
about 30 years in in the world and
they're gonna want air conditioning
they're gonna want all that stuff do
they get the right type of climate
change efficient one so i'll stop with
that but i have great hopes for this
because i don't think we've had a more
decisive moment with apostle than the
civil war with a possible exception of
the huey long father cocklin area under
fdr trust unity pragmatism you would
have made a great president my friend
and who knows navy admiral
patriot really like a true american hero
joe sestak and joe like i'm just so
grateful to you for your friendship um
for your belief and your continued
optimism about what we can do for this
country it's really uh uplifting and
inspiring so thank you and thank you
andrew i so enjoyed you during the
campaign i so enjoyed that you the first
to reach out afterwards and kept contact
afterwards
i truly hope that your service public
service
to a leadership role does go on 40 years
and finally thanks for having me aboard
man thank you for joining
freaky day man we'll put you up in the
admiral seat
thanks andrew very much
you